BUKOLA AYODELE: Many
cloud-native development teams
work with a mix of configuration
systems, APIs, and tools
to manage their infrastructure.
This mix is often
difficult to understand,
leading to reduced velocity
and expensive mistakes.
Let's look at how Alice
uses Config Connector
for consistent GCP
resource management.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Alice is a new engineer
preparing for her first
on call.
She is also worried about
having to learn new commands
to make configuration changes.
Using specialized tools to
solve a plethora of problems
is one of the benefits of
the Linux and microservices
approaches, but it also
comes with added complexity
of having to learn many tools
to do, often, similar tasks.
Many times, it turns out that
these separate components
would have been served if they
allowed you to express what you
want to do without having
to focus on the specific API
to make it happen.
Luckily, Alice has a lot of
experience with K8 toolsheets.
She discovers that
using Config Connecter,
cloud resources are
managed consistently
with K8's native resources,
like pods and services.
Alice realizes
that she can fully
operate the cloud using
her existing K8 expertise
and getops.
And that's the benefit
of Config Connecter.
Config Connector is
a Kubernetes add-on
that allows you to manage
Google Cloud resources
through Kubernetes' manifests.
Because you can manage your
Google Cloud infrastructure
the same way you manage
your Kubernetes application,
complexity and cognitive load
is reduced for developers.
This means more focus
where it matters--
on the infrastructure.
Config Connectors
provide a collection
of Kubernetes' custom
resource definitions,
CRDs, and controllers.
The Config Connector CRDs allow
Kubernetes to create and manage
Google Cloud resources,
like a Cloud SQL database,
the same way Kubernetes
developers are
used to applying Kubernetes'
objects to their clusters.
You configure and apply
objects to your clusters.
Since Alice is already familiar
with Kubernetes' tooling
and declarative workflow,
she is able to use
her existing expertise to
quickly ramp up and manage
the customer's workload.
Let's see a quick example
of this in action.
Alice wants to create a
storage bucket to store images.
The first step is to create
a resource definition, which
uses YAML to specify
the storage bucket's
information, like
its name and what
project it's associated with.
This resource can be updated
through the Kubernetes API
by updating the storage
buckets YAML file.
In this case,
Alice added a label
to the bucket, an annotation
to specify other behaviors
on her storage bucket.
Running the familiar
kubectl commands we already
know and love, like
kubectl apply in this case,
we can create the
storage bucket.
Now, instead of having
to learn another tool,
like the gsutil tool,
Alice was able to use
the knowledge she already had
to create her storage bucket.
All these changes were done
through the Kubernetes API,
which means Alice could apply
the expertise she's already
built up over time
without having
to learn new tools to
manage infrastructure.
That's one of the benefits
of managing GCP resources
with Config Connecter.
In combination with
Config Sync, you also
ensure the change process is
consistent through GitOps,
removing the risk
of config drift.
So that's it for
Config Connecter.
Make sure to check out
the description for links
to more resources on it,
and like and subscribe
to the channel for more
videos about Google Cloud.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]